on savait qu'on ne bouge pas pendant le
djing
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous avez cligner de l'oeil à siliana
c'est possible non c'est pas vous le
dire il est officiellement de boycotter
ce cérémonial stupide et injustifiée
voilà c'est ma position je l'aimais et
je viendrai
[Musique]
la droite
bien alors politiquement quel que soit
votre fidélité à vos engagements de
jeunesse on vous a beaucoup vu ces
derniers temps en compagnie d'alain
madelin
vous avez déclaré d'ailleurs moi un type
dans le programme politique et d'enlever
sa cravate ça me va
vous lui trouvez quoi madelin ba hmad là
je trouve qu'il a il a un discours qui
est particulièrement adaptée à l'époque
dans laquelle nous vivons et je trouve
qu'il ya une modernité est une espèce de
fraternité qui émane de ce discours qui
à mon sens devrait rassembler
pratiquement toutes les couches sociales
de la nation c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
que je vous le voyez mais honnêtement je
le vois à juste titre d'ailleurs
candidat à la présidence de la
république et j'ai la ferme intention et
c'est parce que madelin a enlevé sa
cravate que vous ne portez plus de
cravate c'est une sorte de ma vie
c'était une sorte de mimétisme volée
mais quand le troisième millénaire on
admirait quand on estime quelqu'un dont
on a envie de lui ressembler c'est un
peu comme pour vous tirez vous aimez
bien vous vous êtes mis au sport
fait du vélo avec drucker tous les
dimanches matins avec michel drucker
s'espacent commencer ça se passe pas
bien pour lui parce qu'il a un mal de
chien à me suivre je suis très très
entraînés ça fait des années et des
années que je [ __ ] mais sont les
termes d'ailleurs et lui pour le moment
ils pédalent plutôt dans la choucroute
c'est à dire que il nous est arrivé
d'ailleurs il n'ya pas très longtemps
d'être filmé par ses petits copains de
la 2 et c'était très emmerdant parce que
j'étais obligé de j'étais obligé de
pédaler dans le vide pour qu'ils
puissent me rattrape pas tu dors
beaucoup il dort énormément il
s'économise énormément et je sais pas il
ya quelques jours et quelques jeux
suivront mais peut-être que finalement
là alors il beaucoup plus avec moi à
drucker et donc c'est là où au fond
c'est là la différence pour le téléthon
avait fait 5 fois le tour du
périphérique en vélo 8 peu admiratif x 8
x 8 x 10 7 minutes 46 secondes quatre
dixièmes
alors une des raisons de votre forme
c'est pierre arditi c'est que vous avez
laissé tomber la drogue d'une façon à
peu près complète sauf les pétards mais
enfin bon faudrait une dizaine de
pétards par jour parce que ça remplace
cigarette on faisait arrêter des
cigarettes donc vous êtes obligé de
fumer des pétards à la spa de pas disent
tout de même un pas dit s'il
ya bien un parseur du périphérique voilà
et vous avez retrouvé votre légendaire
énergie sexuelle qui a fait votre succès
faut bien le dire bien d'autres talents
pierre mais avec ça non plus alors b
d'ailleurs grâce à dieu il y avait cette
énergie sexuelle sinon je serais
absolument pas là où je suis aujourd'hui
voilà que pierre a retrouvé en arrêtant
la drogue son énergie sexuelle on vous a
beaucoup vu cet été avec linda hardy à
saint tropez oui et meir et d'autres
copines de la vie voire mort il y avait
nagui avec une blonde décolorée arthur
avec les visions de l'effort et arditi
avec une décolorés brute défi qui a
démarré en amour à mary bale donc c'est
vraiment cool
à son honneur il accorde et quelle durée
c'est parce qu'il va jouer si vous
voulez otages il a donc mary bale s'est
dit tiens alors oui marine rima rebelles
n'est pas content c'était la petite wii
mais lier elle est là elle était là
marie bell on l'applaudît
c'est joli gaston il a un autre
dinosaure il s'appelle mary bale voilà
les cantons enfant va grandir et qui va
tenir papa ya pas assez de buts sur le
plateau dieu tu vas tu as quoi
concrètement je voulais faire revenir
donc oui retourné là en ce moment avec
joyeuses pâques en province il paraît
que c'est surtout de la tournée des
boîtes échangistes c'est à dire que si
vous voulez ça fait quand même une bonne
dizaine d'années que
un peu plus même une douzaine d'années
que mr barbier m'avait dit que qu'au
fond sa clientèle son public on le
fabrique qu'en province et j'ai suivi ce
conseil à la lettre et c'est d'ailleurs
blier lui-même qui m'avait dit que je
pouvais justement profiter voilà
l'avantagé des tournées c'est sa fille
voilà et donc ça fait une bonne douzaine
d'années maintenant que je fais plein de
boîtes échangistes vous donnerai des
adresses intéressera sûrement d'ailleurs
connaître j'ai l'intention d'éditer un
guide safia le trio il ya le gardien des
boîtes et jean gravity des boîtes
échangistes le arditi avec un achat
heard it il a redit qu'il vous a choqué
beaucoup de monde quand même avec votre
mercedes vitres fumées sur la roue et je
vous fait allumer des cigarettes par des
assistants ne trouvez pas que c'est un
peu too much mais vous savez moi je vais
vous dire quand on a réussi après tout
c'est ça ouais hein quand on a du pognon
quand on a du mal et on sait bien dans
éclaboussé
maison qu'à se démerder pour faire la
même chose voilà
on reconnait on reconnaît vraiment le
may be missed le choc le libéral le
libéral de choc alors ben on va terminer
avec la littérature fait des lectures
publiques aussi dans les villes où vous
vous allez vous lisez du renaud camus
vous lisez du robert brasillach du
nietzsche oui c'est des jeux les jeux
les découvrir sur le tard et je dois
dire que j'ai eu tort ouais c'est un
manque de culture de ma part très bon il
celui là encore il ya une parole
importante à proférer aujourd'hui il ya
une pensée que qu'on ne partage pas
suffisamment et en particulier dans les
couches basses de la société qu'ils ne
lisent pas comme tout le monde le sait
je voudrais être le chantre au fond de
cette parole vous la tendance à
atteindre et je ne vois pas pour mes
élèves voulaient être vos lectures de
brasillach sont remarquables et voilà il
antisémitisme ça vous choque plus du
tout un fût un temps où ça vous énervez
maintenant vous vivez avec bah qu'est ce
que vous voulez nous finalement c'est
dans l'air du temps alors après tout
pourquoi pas hein voilà
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu